[Music]
okay
let's move on
and i'll talk about improving
calculation as well later
another perk we've had the perk okay c6
so this is um
this isn't it is a line uh but we don't
have to do anything particularly
different
from what we normally do okay i'm
tempted to play knight d5
because this guy's gonna probably
pre-move like b6 or something
but what should we do how should we
how should we continue our development
in the simple way
so we have several approaches here we
can we can choose to to occupy more of
the center with f4
that would be possible but let's let's
play the comm move with knight f3
and now let's of course develop this
bishop to c4
and we're going to dismantle this the
hell out of this line
okay now bishop g4 pins our knight
uh and by pinning our knight he's
exerting indirect pressure on the d4
pawn
so where should we put this bishop with
an eye toward that
well bishop f7 doesn't work because of
queen f7 he thinks he's cool
but we're going to show him that he's
not this should be threes right
this is why you shouldn't be afraid of
these kinds of players who like
do all this stuff really fast now here's
an interesting question well which side
do we castle we can actually castle
queen side that would be risky but
before we decide which side to castle on
i am annoyed as hell about this
pit in theoretically how can we dispose
of this pin without moving the bishop to
a passive square
h3g4 now what would h3g4 mean
uh in terms of where we castle like if
you think about it if we played h3g4
where do we basically commit to castling
we basically commit to castlement
but that's okay because he's developed
so poorly that it's okay for us to
telegraph the past okay he's not going
to checkmate us he doesn't have anything
out
his pieces are passive he's full of
weaknesses let's get rid of the pen
and since we've decided to castle
queenside well let's fricken castle
queenside
queen e2 castle and uh then we're going
to start attacking on the king side even
though he's not castled
no that doesn't matter that doesn't mean
we can't attack on the king's side
we need to queen d2 eeny meeny miny moe
i'll go queen e2
so that the rook has is the star of the
show on the default now do we need to
defend
um this square um
i would say no probably not
let me think actually yeah no we can
just castle
and if he takes we'll i'll i'll show why
i think that's the case well we can try
to trap the bishop but he's probably not
gonna allow it
okay so here's the thing the thing is
we are ahead in development the
immediate association that you should
make
is to opening up the center so first
step is to open up the center a little
bit more
so that we can better exploit our lead
in developments
okay interesting position
and i have a very interesting question
what should we capture here
and this is not an obvious answer at all
there's actually three things that are
entirely plausible
to capture here and all three have a
compelling case to be made for them
we can actually take f7 and lure the
king onto f7 sacrificing our bishop
and try to checkmate him shall we do
that we can actually also play e takes
d7
yeah let's do it daniel style let's go
let's punish him for this
let's let's get our hands dirty here
because his whole queen side is
undeveloped now this is risky because
it's a whole piece
and if you consolidate now where should
we go from now the obvious move is e
takes d6 opening up more of the center
but there is also another move that is
more concrete in its intentions
but also potentially more powerful in
its
conclusion which is e6 to prepare queen
f7 checkmate
uh i don't know which move is better but
we'll see
okay bishop f6 that's a good move um
and now we we need to somehow find a way
to start breaking down his defenses and
at the core of his defenses
is this pawn on d6 now g5 is very
tempting i know you guys are tempted by
that
but he just goes bishop e5 and that
actually doesn't accomplish as much as
it seems because the queen defends f7 so
we are going to play the move bishop f4
this is the kind of move
which a lot of people at the 1600 level
struggle with at any level
because it doesn't look it doesn't carry
that kind of pizzazz which you associate
with the attacks
but remember attacks have to have those
what i call
glue moves ah ladies and gentlemen
we've opened up the d-file what does
that mean
this would be checkmate were it not for
the queen
which we can distract with rook d8 and
give the checkmate
and what move contributed to that that's
the glue move bishop f4
okay prepare slowly attack fast
good game so
all right um so he went here
and so just to dispel
yeah let's dispel the fiction that he
doesn't know what he's doing so
let's dispel with one um illusion which
is that
it's not about how much of the central
center you control
it's about the quality of the pawns in
the center
by which i mean uh you can put
you know a million pawns in the center
and you'll lose half of them
congratulations you're controlling the
center
okay but it's more important to to
occupy a little bit of the center
but make sure that that little bit is
supported by the pieces
okay so knight c3 queen c7
we got to put it all in the lockbox
knight f3 uh e5 just this is all very
natural development
and now g4 bishop g6 queen e2 preparing
to castle long
castles long sacrificing the pawn
um and could you have captured bishop f7
one move sooner than checked in with his
knight
and recount oh so just to clarify
this is a very typical tactic when the
bishop is undefended
uh and the idea is you draw the king out
and go knight g5 and
queen takes g4 which is all well and
good but you have to factor in the queen
so full board vision queen takes f7 that
doesn't work
uh but if the queen was not on f7 by the
way if the queen was on d8
this would also not work why if the
queen was on d8 this would also not work
why is that and that is something people
very often miss
or forget about and you can actually
catch some people on this trap
let's let's actually imagine the queen
of san diego
so the queen could just take the knight
that's actually crucial
boom the queen simultaneously defends
the bishop and if you count up the
pieces
black is just up a piece here which is
uh which is bad so that's that's
something to bear in mind as well
uh so anyways uh fast forward to
the moment of truth the obvious move
here
was yeah we need to i thought the queen
might come to f3 one day the obvious
move is queen f3 but but the reason i
didn't do this is because of d5
he he closes in the bishop
uh and then he has a he has a tempo
which you can use to at least
castle which does not make the king
particularly safe but it makes it a
little bit harder to reach
uh but the capture that some people
might be forgetting about is e takes d6
you might be looking at this whoa what
is this i mean you're allowing black to
take the queen but
but look one step further you take uh
black's queen
and this pawn it's not so much that it
threatens to take the knight although
that too
is a big threat you actually threatened
to promote
black has to prevent this by moving his
knight away
but now you come back and take the
bishop and if you count the material you
are up upon
which you can then defend with bishop f4
so it's not easy for black to win this
fun
white is winning in the end game so if i
was playing a classical game i would
probably go for this
but we decided on the sort of
enterprising move no bishop f7 is the
top computer move
so it's hilarious all three moves lead
to a clear advantage i checked but here
um i think e6 is actually not the best i
think we should have gone here
and and maybe uh queen f5 queen e6 just
the sort of
more dinosaur approach open everything
up and
and get your pieces to get squares but
we played e6
and now we play the glue move bishop f4
and how does this move function it
functions because
you want to eliminate the d6 spot why is
it important to eliminate 56 spawn
because
not because it's a free pawn but because
that is the key to black's kingdom if
you can open up the d-file
that's a crucial artery to black's king
and
if you think about it we already have
one artery or one avenue
but that's uh defended by the queen if
there's going to be two
avenues and we saw this happen exactly
in the game
that's like screaming an overloading
tactic
so to find overloading tactics you need
to identify situations
where there's two potential mating
squares
both of which are defended by one piece
and so
you can overwhelm that piece by
sacrificing one piece on one mating
square
and then that vacates the other one so
rook d7 also would be possible by the
way yeah
but rook d7 queen d7 would keep black in
the game for the time being
knight takes c7 and black is still
breathing although queen b3 basically
kills him
because of this so of course this would
be winning
but rook d8 is much much cleaner
so hopefully this uh this makes sense to
everybody
okay um so that was a nice game and we
we dismantled this uh
unsuccessful attempt at an intimidating
opening setup
no knight takes doesn't work of course
because that's the whole point of rook
d7 right
because that that blocks the queen's
control of f7
yeah that's that's the sort of purpose
of rook d7 interception tactic
or interference i think it's called
okay let's continue one more
and then we'll probably call it because
i have a lesson soon
all right but after such hype i i have
to i have to continue
okay so again we're gonna go for a
sicilian
and again it goes f4 so i guess it's a
popular line okay
so we literally just had this but i
don't think it's the same guy
okay so this guy plays bishop e2 uh the
the previous guy played c3 so we don't
actually need to play t4 here we can
we can develop and here
we can well we don't have the d5 square
but we do have the g
okay knight h4 um that's interesting
and that throws a bit of a wrinkle in
our in our plan because if we go knight
g6
we allow him to take our bishop and that
kind of ruins our
our structure on in the center so what
we should do is we should we should flip
the the order of our pieces we should go
bishop g6 and then vacate that square
for the knight
now again we can go d4 but this time
let's actually play it without d4
let's go knight f5 why is it
okay if he takes our bishop we would
have taken with the h pawn and opened up
that
file toward his king okay d4 would be a
mistake okay so he tries to trade all of
our pieces
which is kind of an annoying strategy
but um it would be fine
to trade here but what else could we do
here
what what else could we do here
yeah g4 was a thing but i'll explain how
we would have dealt with that yeah
bishop d3 is a nice move
let's see what he does yeah and now we
can go back to g6 so the whole purpose
of that if we went to g6 immediately he
would have been able to go f5
and sort of broken up the center now the
bishop is
safe and sound and we can just go bishop
e7
okay he's going back to g4 but now f5 is
no longer dangerous
because we've already castled and made
our king safe so that f5 would just
blunder up
yeah i mean what exactly do we do here
what do we do here
he's annoying but he was too persistent
like he uh
he was too stubborn in in in trying to
accomplish his plan he doesn't again
everything comes back to
not developing well enough right that's
the root of all problems the root of all
evil now what should we take back with
another very instructive moment and
again i'm going to give you guys a hint
we can violate a rule here and it would
be justified
so the instinct that everybody has i
know is to take with a knight to
preserve the pawns or
to take with the h fund but is anybody
thinking about maybe taking with the
f one so that we can open up a file
why is it important to open up a file
here because he's not developed
so an open file is a ticking time bomb
for him
plus it's hard for him to develop
because he can't go knight d2
because of knight takes d3 that was good
timing
um it's gonna go in the youtube video
and um okay so knight f3 now
the immediate instinct is to move the
knight away but there's really nowhere
to move it but that's that's okay we've
anticipated that
what can we do here who wants to
yeah c4 bingo what move do we prepare
by playing c4 in addition to supporting
the knight
which we play now
absolutely and it's all pouring in
smothered made ideas rook to e8 of
bishop e3
the game is okay t4 let's get this
rukovich in
and this is going to be devastating he
has to play bishop e3 now
[Music]
simple he never developed his bishop
and by extension he never developed the
rook
so of course and guess which file
guess which file we delivered the
checkmate on the f file
which we opened by playing fdx g6 so you
can see very directly the
benefit of opening up a file when your
opponent lacks development now you have
to be careful about that
because you also want to make sure that
you're accounting for the price that you
pay for this right if he manages to
consolidate then yes
we've weakened our pawn structure and we
sort of disattached
one pawn island from the other pawn
island which is definitely
a price of admission but i judged that
it was worth it because
i knew that he had a very hard time
developing his pieces here
now what should white have done here how
should he have gone about
trying to develop his queen side there's
a very specific move that he didn't play
here which he should have played
and it was really the only chance for
him to quickly develop his queen side
okay not sure what c4 does i mean you
could just take
well d4 d4 targets the symptoms but not
the disease
although you're right yeah you could try
this but bishop f4 is what i meant i
actually meant a simpler move bishop f4
developing with tempo and then you could
move the knight out to d2 now
still we could take a page out of his
book and try to trade the bishops and
then get a queen here so
uh i still think black is doing great
here but that that that was what he
should have done
uh and the funny thing is
so okay the opening was very clear
knight g6 here would be bad because yeah
so we go bishop g6 and that's a very
common idea in the karokan
sort of you know switch i don't know
what to call this like the flippage of
pieces
from f5 to g6 and then the other the
other piece
occupies the square recently vacated
it's a good chance to come up with some
sort of a name
uh can we go knight d4 yeah 94 is
possible we can centralize the night
absolutely um and and we can go after
this bishop too
uh so that would be a great move
actually the switcheroo
now some people asked about g4 and yes
g4 would be annoying
particularly since bishop g6 would run
into f5
but this is where i always say do not
stop
calculating when it seems like the line
is over
take and i call this the 15 second rule
i've never introduced this before
now i'll put it this way my students are
very divided on whether this is bs
or the most helpful thing in the world
so some of my
students have said like look i've given
this a chance i think you're full of it
this doesn't actually help um but some
have said
this is like really really helped me i
call this the 15 second rule
so when you're calculating a variation
and you're about to stop
calculating uh you take an additional 15
seconds
just to make sure that you didn't miss
any additional resources
okay that's as simple as that now you
don't need to do that
in every line that you calculate but
only in like the important lines
what do i mean by important lines i mean
look if bishop g6
worked then our position would be really
really good so we really want this to
work
so if you're really trying to make a
move work
and you find that it doesn't work force
yourself to stare at the final position
in which you abandon the line
because maybe you allow your brain to
gather some more data about the position
and find a resource
boom boom boom
attacking the king attacking the pawn
white can block with bishop g4
and you can go bishop h5 pinning the
bishop
and white's position collapses so
hopefully that makes sense anyways i'll
talk more about that later
so here here here now if he had gone d4
um how would we have gone about
attacking
this pawn
and this is a very typical queen b6 and
this shows you the danger of having
see this is where you see that it's not
about
how many pawns you have in the center
but the quality of the pawns in the
center because white can't contain his
center
bishop e3 blunders the pawn of b2 so he
loses the pawn on d4
it's a classic uh classic trope so he
went f5 which was asking for trouble
f takes g6 knight e3 and look at all of
our pieces come in one after the other
bishop knight queen
knight bishop rook rook checkmate
down the f5 bingo
questions
all right good
very very good um this was a this was a
nice game
um and let's play one last one encore
encore i'm feeling good
chess man we're having a lot of black
games today
uh but okay we'll play another sicilian
okay queen f3 great he's probably gonna
go here
nope okay so again there is no need to
change our strategy
because our opponent is playing
something dumb so we can just develop
our pieces
okay and
there's two fundamental approaches that
we can
take here one is to panda with a
thousand bits thank you one is to
open up the center immediately with d5
but i don't recommend that because that
could potentially justify
the placement of the queen uh
so let's actually prepare well we can
prepare d5 let's prepare d5 let's go e6
and d5 just so that
we get a nicer more robust pawn center
also it's very important to realize that
we're not going to beat this in in two
moves okay we need to play methodically
we need to develop our pieces and we
can't play our opponents game here okay
we should we should play okay so this
move almost loses
one second
yeah it's very close because 95 almost
drops the queen but he has queen e3
uh he has queen e3 and that square is is
relatively safe so there's no need for
that yet let's castle
let's castle let's see what he does oh
ladies and gentlemen why is this a bad
move horrible
this is a this move will kill him
immediately i mean in the next like five
moves
and he can't even get his nut he's
probably going to go knowing the type of
guy that this guy is bishop d1
he's probably going to go bishop d1
thinking that he's going to develop the
knight c2 but we're going to show him
who's boss here watch him go bishop d1
that would actually be kind of sick
but no i actually can't predict can't
predict these people's moves i mean he
can literally do anything under god's
blue sky
yeah g4 okay um now
rookie a now obviously if he goes g5
which he probably will um yeah there was
no way i could predict that
then we obviously okay queen g2 fiance
is queen great
now he wants to go knight f3 which is a
noble intention
we have so many good moves here i
literally we could fill up a book
with the amount of good moves that we
have we could go 95
and the simplest is to go knight i would
have gone queen e7 to stop him from
going knight f3 by the way
but this is also good because if he goes
knight f3 obviously
we have checks on d3 and out of four
with a huge fork
so he moves his king great bond cloud on
top of everything else
but this is the moment where a lot of
people struggle we need to strike while
the iron is hot we have
most of our pieces developed so we need
to open things up before he gets a
chance to consolidate how should we go
about doing that there's two tempting
moves one of them is a mistake
the other is good so there's d4 and c4
d4 is a mistake because it allows him to
go c4
and it closes up the center now why is
it not symmetrical what if he goes d4
here
yeah well he does what's the difference
in this line what's the catch
and we've already seen this before just
in a previous game today
the catches that we have this d3 square
and we have the same situation where we
have this chain reaction of outposts
that have opened up
in addition to this monster pawn sitting
on d3 which by the way is not easy to
win
there we go it's exactly like that
previous game queenies ooh we need
someone
a sexy move instead i mean look at this
look at our fonts here
and on top of those pawns are going to
appear a bunch of pieces as well
so um this is actually horrendous for
white
and again it's going to take us a while
to actually break this down
but it's not a race uh it's it's okay he
continues to push his pawns
so there's just so many things we can do
here um okay one good way of getting to
his position would be to go queen a5 and
i'll explain this move in a second
what we're trying to do is do this but
the immediate queen a4 is not as
effective
for what reason why why is queen a4
not um not that if it because of b how
should we prepare queen a4
by which i mean how should we prepare
against the move b3
we should go bishop e6 first exactly and
then we go queen a4 and if b3 we can
just take on b3
and then take the rook if he takes back
we can even take okay thank you for
helping us
he literally just you know
just abandons any ability to even play
b3
and now we're gonna get right into his
grill here and we can actually build a
little queen bishop battery right in his
face and go guindy one mate
that would be one way to win if he goes
bishop d2
then he drops b2 and he drops all the
other pawns
although we don't even need to take it i
can actually show you guys a cool one
there
so yeah this is just sorry i mean g6 is
ridiculously
ridiculously innocuous okay goodbye
let's blow him to smithereens here
rook h2 yeah this guy is fooling around
but um
you know this is not always that easy to
beat uh and and sometimes this kind of
works against people who get intimidated
and that's understandable
but hopefully if i've you know had one
impact on
on you guys in the speed run it's that
you're no longer intimidated by
all of these weird systems okay
so what should we do here
well we should first let's first take
the rook
and we have a very nice move very
thematic move in this position just
blast everything open blast it all open
e3 fv rookie 3 and the queen is
undefended
which is actually a very important thing
to observe here
otherwise this would not have worked uh
so we still need to be
accurate and we still need to make the
proper observations
oh he has this uh he's actually quite
slippery
let's get the other rook into the game
he's actually quite slippery believe it
or not and now we have rookie 2 as an
idea
we could have done that first it doesn't
matter
yeah so now rookie 4 makes sense to try
to
separate the queen from the bishop and
then if he goes queen f2 when he goes
queen f2 we're going to go rookie 2.
no he doesn't do that he goes there give
us that please thank you
and then rookie 1 mate is going to be
the threat as well as rook f4
yeah this is over and he resigns good
game
so a good lesson in how to how to uh
beat these kinds of systems um
yeah so notice that we we didn't play d5
immediately because
the funny thing is this could have
justified
the placement of the queen and this is
still bad for white i mean we can go e6
but you don't need to rush to play d5 in
every instance
so we go e6 then d5
um then we just develop now 95 again
doesn't trap the queen because of queen
e3 and then he can play f4
so that would be hasty but he opens up
the e file for us which we occupy
then the move c4 very instructive
opening up the position or creating an
outpost on d3
which we occupy well 4 200 subs that's
ridiculous
incredible guys thank you now we create
this pawn wedge
and we find a way to make inroads into
his position so literally
you identify a pathway to his king
it's not rocket science okay i saw that
this was one potential pathway
and i asked myself what is stopping us
from accessing the king through that
pathway well wants to move b3
how can we go about taking the sting out
of b3 we can go bishop e6 first
by the way if he takes the pawn we can
just go bishop b actually
this is actually not that simple because
now the queen is hanging but uh
i suppose we could give a check first
and then a check and then a check and
then take the queen
so that would be one way of
circumventing that
yeah we get here here queenie two is not
mate i think some people were this is
also not mate but uh the knight is
defending the square
so e3 breaking through
and uh just taking everything so very
simple game but nonetheless i think a
good
again a good lesson in in preventing uh
and in dealing with
uh this kind of crap that that some
people play
um so instead of bishop h2
chessgamertag says queen takes d2
um well then king takes and this is not
checkmate although it's very close but
it's that's another thing you want to
watch out for you want to be careful
about getting too fancy
in situations where you're completely
winning sometimes the business-like
approach
is a lot better